Avengers infinity war features more
super characters than you can shake a
cosmically powered stick at most of them
you know and many of them have had their
own movies already even the guardians of
the galaxy crew is pretty familiar at
this point but some of the supporting
characters remain a little obscure for
instance what's the deal with nebula the
bald blue skinned cyborg played by Karen
Gillan how is her Comics incarnation
different from her character in the MCU
let's explore
Thanos granddaughter when nebula first
appeared in Avengers number 257 Thanos
wasn't even around he'd been turned to
stone years earlier and although he
wasn't technically dead he was just as
out of the picture one of the first
actions nebula took in those comics was
to claim fan OSes former headquarters
the sanctuary two for her own when
starfox Thanos's brother claimed it as
his familial right nebula made the claim
that would come to define her the space
station was rightfully hers because
Thanos was her grandfather old look in
her early appearances nebula looked very
different from the bald cyborg she would
eventually become she was a fully
organic humanoid alien with gauntlets
that enabled her to fire destructive
beams from her wrists she had long
bluish black hair that rose up in big
curls on the sides in one of those
hairstyles that's only possible in
comics nebula belongs to a race called
the loofah modes there are only a few of
them left in the galaxy because Galactus
ate the planet of free foam and only
those loofah modes who were off planet
survived other loofah modes like Zoar a
villain who first appeared in nova
number one were desperate to find a new
homeworld for their people
nebula never seemed interested in that
being a space pirate and the leader of a
fleet of mercenaries seemed to be her
truest calling no love from grandpa
whether nebula was being honest about
her relation to Thanos was never
particularly relevant as long as he
wasn't actually around being a pirate
and mercenary gave her plenty to do in
the universe hopping Marvel comics of
the 1980s of course is all classic
villains eventually will Thanos return
to life resurrected by Death herself in
Silver Surfer number 38 he met the woman
who claimed to be his granddaughter he
was not impressed and claimed never to
have fathered children
it was probably meant to be the truth at
the time but became a lie in light of
later stories because
comics are very complicated declaring
nebulas lies unforgivable Thanos set her
on fire with beams from his eyes he
meant to kill her but crew members on
the sanctuary to saved her life in a
manner of speaking when Thanos
rediscovered nebula after the first
meeting she had been burned beyond
recognition profoundly brain-damaged and
about to expire for real by this time
Thanos had assembled the infinity gems
into the Infinity Gauntlet giving
himself vast and godlike powers he used
those powers to stop nebula for croaking
without actually healing her she existed
as a shambling nearly mindless charged
zombie of a creature fan OSes downfall a
confrontation with the cosmic being
known as eternity led to Thanos leaving
his body unattended while his
consciousness dealt with larger cosmic
matters this gave nebula who had been
repeatedly described as nearly mindless
the opportunity to grab the Infinity
Gauntlet off his hand and claim its
power for herself
immediately restoring her body and mind
in the process she didn't keep the
gauntlet for long but she enabled the
defeat of Thanos
and was restored from her zombie-like
state in the process bald is beautiful
after the events of the Infinity
Gauntlet nebulas physical form was
restored but her brain was still damaged
her longtime first Mei Jia Tarr freed
her from imprisonment and took her to a
rogue Space surgeon who promised to
restore her faculties when the fully
restored nebula was finally unveiled in
Silver Surfer number 72 she'd become a
bald cyborg who should look very
familiar to Marvel Cinematic Universe
fans finally back to her mental and
physical peak even beyond it thanks to
her cybernetic implants nebula returned
to the life of a space pirate amazing
graces in annihilation Ronan one of the
miniseries that was part of Marvel's
longer 2006 annihilation event nebula
was reintroduced as a member of a team
of interstellar women warriors known as
the graces the leader of the graces
turned out to be a woman with an even
stronger connection to Thanos the nebula
herself ever had Gamora
whereas nebula only ever claimed to be
the granddaughter of Thanos a claim
never proven Gamora was actually raised
by him when Nicole Perlman and Jay
gun were writing guardians of the galaxy
for the screen and figuring out how to
translate all the complex mythology
around Thanos to the Cinematic Universe
a story emerged that was simpler and
more powerful than anything nebula and
Gamora had dealt with in the comics a
story about sisters MCU update the
nebula of the guardians of the galaxy
movies is like Gamora and adopted
daughter of Thanos
unlike the fully organic Gamora nebula
has been enhanced with extremely visible
cybernetics leaving her a mix of woman
and machine who suffers doubts about her
own self hood her self-doubt combined
with a close relationship with Gamora
enables nebula to turn against Thanos
and become a sympathetic character and a
grudging ally to the heroes she refuses
to join the guardians of the galaxy but
by the end of their second movie she's
no longer the group's enemy in fact her
new stated mission is to destroy Thanos
herself
I will help them by killing bad odds
setting up her appearances in Avengers
infinity war and it's as yet untitled
sequel thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]